on va partir du côté de la haute saône à
vesoul où nous attend une nouvelle
députée qui n'a jamais siégé ce sera son
premier mandat elle était candidate pour
la république en marche c'est barbara
beso vallot tout simplement votre
sentiment
vous êtes la nouvelle députée de la
première circonscription de haute saône
ce soir comment vous sentez je me sens
fier fier et j'ai cette fois ci une
nouvelle mission et
il me tarde d'aller voir tout ce qui se
passe de prendre ses fonctions et de
commencer à travailler dès demain matin
vous faites partie madame b somalo de
ses vrais novice en politique de la
république en marche vous n'avez exercer
aucun mandat qu'elle a acquis vous avez
pensé ce soir
quand vous avez su que vous étiez élu
député de la nation à mes grands parents
qui m'ont éduqué petit et qui m'ont
donné des vraies de vraies valeurs
et quand on sème un canton c'est mon
récolte barbara beso ballot il ya une
petite anecdote vous concernant serre
que vous n'êtes pas la seule femme de
votre famille à avoir gagné une élection
ce week-end puisque votre fille s'est
aussi imposé mais dans une autre
élection celle de miss haute-saône
j'imagine que ça ça va c'est quand même
la fête et c'est un week-end très
particulier pour vous ça pourrait être
un week-end particulier je pense qu'on
va s'en souvenir longtemps effectivement
c'est la fête n'ont paradoxalement c'est
pas du bonheur ou être heureux je pense
que ces choses assez beaucoup plus
intime
en tout cas c'est un grand sentiment de
fierté est effectivement jeanne a été
brillante et on en a été fier bien
entendu en tant que parent